une éclaircie au dessus des filets
jaunes loin de là le futur gel de la
hausse des taxes sur les carburants au
1er janvier est très loin d'avoir apaisé
leur colère comme ici à dijon cette
annonce gouvernementale ne va rien
changer à la lutte des français ça c'est
alsa minimum se déguise annoncé un
minimum pour repartir sur autre chose
maintenant faut carrément baissé les
taxes au majeure partie et quand j le
smic le smic va l'augmenter d'augmenter
les salaires
je me relance et d'économie un moratoire
c'est à dire que dans trois mois il va
nous les remettre et dans trois mois on
se retrouvera plus encore une fois dans
la rue et c'est la colère va monter dans
trois mois donc il faut trouver des
solutions maintenant une cacahuète une
miette une goutte d'eau autant de mots
qui reviennent dans la bouche des gilet
jaune pour qualifier cette mesure comme
ici au creusot le mouvement ne faiblit
pas car leurs revendications depuis
longtemps dépassé cette demande initiale
du mouvement il n'y a pas que ça la
hausse de carburant c'est bien pour les
gens qui se déplacent tous travaillent
et qui n'ont pas de transport comme ici
dans les campagnes mais il ya tout le
reste il ya les salaires on demande plus
sain parce que quand on voit la
précarité qui a partout au niveau des
retraités les jeunes les étudiants y
aura beaucoup qui peuvent pas continuer
parce que valait pas d'argent pour payer
les études et/ou puis de pouvoir d'achat
le carburant du sahara non insuffisante
et trop tardive cette première réponse
d'apaisement du gouvernement ne semblent
donc pas pour l'heure trouvé l'écho
espéré